last week Muhammad rod one who stabbed a
PCS Stuart Orton six times at the head
with a machete
was convicted of wounding with intent
why why not attempted murder because if
ever there was a clear case of it
PC lying bleeding in the road with six
great holes in the skull was it yet rod
one who's got previous four machetes got
only 16 years and probably weren't so
close to that when he was arrested the
convicted rapist said a PC my life's
worth more than his and that's what's
got to change a criminals belief that a
bobbies life is worthless and can be
taken at will we expect policemen to
take risks we're to care scare - which
is why violent thugs need to know that
if you try to kill them it's a whole
life sentence no ifs no buts there were
more than 10,000 violent attacks on
coppers last year so if you want more
police like Stewart looking out for us
they have to know we value their lives
and the risks they take to keep us safe
[Music]
Carol that was a horrifying case but I
don't think that we should extrapolate
law on the basis of one case and change
sentencing policy and principle I think
that sentencing has to always be
balanced with rehabilitation if you're
arguing that anybody who attacks a
police officer should get a mandatory
life sentence where does where does
rehabilitation I said it twice to kill
attempted murder
where does rehabilitation coming which
is part of the point of prison I think
to know what we're talking about here we
have to have a look this is the video
and an answer and I have to issue a
warning this video shows some of the
violence during the attack and in the
immediate aftermath
if that wasn't attempted murder I don't
know that was six slashes to his head
and two to his arms I just want to read
something because I haven't seen that I
think it's appropriate to read the
statement of the officer himself BCR
alton after the conviction because it's
really an example of something consent
consummate professionalism coming from
this police officer he said he had no
hatred for the attacker and then he said
which I found amazing he said he did
what he did
he's now paying the price for it I don't
feel the attack was personal he was
attacking an officer in uniform and I
responded as such I mean the
professionalism of this man is amazing
it raises another point though to your
point which is should there be harsher
offenses for attacking a man in uniform
a woman in attempt now attempted murder
in fact why don't we hear from the
police officer himself I took six
machete strikes to the head and two to
the arm and I can see some of the scars
now yeah visible scars all over my head
visible scar on my right hand visible
scar my right forearm and everyone's
that will never go away
did you always think you had come
through it or were you frightened any
point there was a point where I'm on all
fours bloods coming up my head like a
tap and I kind of think to myself I'm a
little bit of trouble here to the point
where I'll think to myself if I don't
I'll focus in on my breathing just
thinking if I slow my breathing down I
could slow my heart rate slow the blood
loss stop myself from passing out
because if I pass out I can't guarantee
that I can keep control of myself and
feed myself keep my heart beating so to
speak it's what it's what's known as an
aggravating factor so lower charges
attempted murder or wounding with intent
but lower chose it because it needs to
be said paramedics unbelievably get
attacked as well sometimes for their
drugs so there is something already
before the court I would argue clearly
it's not working
we heard the figure than you quoted the
high level of attacks and you're
absolutely right so we need to revisit
that it was only within the last two
years that was introduced I think it
needs to be freshened up but just coming
back to your your initial point there is
no doubt that police officer would have
died had he not had his taser he would
have so how that cannot be attempted
murder because he would we would now be
mourning the death of a very brave young
let me just say the thing that he said
is my life is worth more than his and
that's what we've got to change because
when you attack an officer of the law
when you try to kill or if you do kill
him you're attacking the fundamental
basis of our society you're attacking
law and order and I and I believe that
while all attempted murders are serious
I think the attempted murder of a
policeman warrants a life sentence I
just I'm struggling to get my head
around the idea that it wasn't attempted
murder the the criteria for murder are I
need to attempt to cause grievous bodily
harm and they need to then lead to death
as a cut away from from murder
if you slash somebody in the head with a
machete several times you're attempting
to cause be was probably harm it is that
simple
Carol can I bring us I think we all
agree that if you attack a police
officer anybody in a uniform who's
trying to serve society keep the peace
look after our citizens they should have
a higher sentence but we do have the
largest prison population in Europe
there are 80,000 men 4,000 women
represented that this government is
spending 2.5 billion pounds on building
new prisons we've also got to address
that issue as well as saying although
Carol we've got to address the issue we
do have overcrowded prisons we have
prison officers who are signing off for
stress because the prisons are so
overcrowded rehabilitation has got to be
at a premium
given the current crisis in prison so
you don't see if policemen are protected
that you know I'm amazed Stewart out has
not left as many would have walked away
but many still will if if they'd if
they're not sufficiently protected and
you say the prisons I thought they're
going to be an awful lot more fall if
there's a breakdown of law and order and
there will be because there won't be
enough cops joining the force to keep
law in disguise
if not just to watch waiting facial
recognition I just think we criminals
have to be disabused of the fact that a
police officers life is worth worker and
16 years in jail for that if not spend
two-thirds he won't he was even though
the goodbye might get scrapped the end
they're halfway scheme he could still
serve just 2/3 I'm just it took me a
while I got over my initial furious
seeing what the hell just happened that
that man was there but remembering who
we are as a society and just basic
morality if he put me in jail for one
year and I come out I'm not the same
person I mean they're worse or I'm
better if we if we if that person is
still having the same activity as now of
my life is worth more than his etc you
should stay in the prison for as long as
he has that attitude
however we we recently saw Jack Merritt
literally die for the principle that
rehabilitation is a fund of fundamental
part of our justice system and if we
have a system that make sure people who
go into prisons are properly
rehabilitated then by a certain time
they should be allowed leave if we know
for for certain vote for well at least
it certainly can be
machetes before he's also a convicted
rapist the man was gonna be
rehabilitation before the rehabilitation
question Street questioned why this
wasn't a charge of and conviction for
its interview you know why you know why
they do it the cops put two charges that
but what if wounding and one of
attempted murder because with attempted
murder you have to prove intent if you
can't prove that then you at least you
get the wounding charges leading charge
can be up to like six and seventeen
years so they do it as a double measure
but in this case it's a clear-cut case
there should have been attempted murder
and that kind of does away with the
rehabilitation arguing because question
is what charge really a face had been
convicted for and I don't think anyone
on this table disputes that attempted
murder is life just to clarify rod when
was charged and acquitted of attempted
murder but let's now hear from the
Justice Secretary Robert Buckland who
speaks to your point about Carroll about
how people aren't confident that people
are being put away
for the correct length of time and what
he says time and again victims tell me
they feel let down by a system that can
see violent and sexual offenders back on
the streets after serving just half
their sentence so we will end the
automatic halfway release for these
offenders ensuring punishment truly fits
the crime and restores the public's
faith in the justice system just want to
point out between eighty two thousand
eighteen nineteen ten thousand three
hundred and ninety nine attacks on copy
that what were injured in every single
one of them yeah well okay we've got to
move on i'm afraid from that debate
you're watching a pledge on sky news up
next the importance of remembering the
liberation of Auschwitz seventy five
years on
[Music]